[موسيقى]
في تجربتي وانا عميد دراسات عليا السابق
واشرفت على الاف من الرسائل العلميه في
الازهر وخارج الازهر ايضا المشكله
الاساسيه في التعليم في تنشئه الطالب
العلماء الاقدمون يقولون العالم لابد ان
يقوم بواجب الوقت يعني ايه يعني الدراسات
الجامعيه عندما تصنع رسائل علميه ماجستير
دكتوراه لازم هذه الرسائل العلميه تخدم
المجتمع تحل قضايا المجتمع لكن معظم
الرسائل العلميه في وادي اجتمع في وادي
اخر
[موسيقى]
تجد مثلا ان طالبا وكثير يبحث عن مخطوطات
في التفسير في الحديث في اصول الفقه قديمه
ليس فيها جديد ثم ياتي ويحققها ويخرجها
ويطبعه وتزيد كتب الاصول كتبا وتزيد كتب
الحديث كتبا كتب التفسير طب ما الجديد انا
اقول ان نبحث عن رسائل علميه تخاطب
المجتمع تخاطب حياه الناس
[موسيقى]
العلماء يقولون من هو المجتهد يقول
للمجتهد هو الذي يدرك النص الشرعي بعدين
قالو يدرك الواقع المعيش وبعدين هو كيف
ينزل النص على الواقع يعني الواقع متغير
[موسيقى]